[Musique]
le sport a ses légendes
et avec elles naissent de grandes
rivalités comme celle entre les anciens
champions de tennis mcenroe et connor ce
nous celle des deux géants actuels de la
formule 1 hamilton et vettel il paraît
que tu as touché ma voiture bref il
laisse regarder tu la regardes et tu as
touché indique qu'il a touchés
cependant ce genre de concurrence a
inspiré des générations de jeunes
athlètes du monde entier
de la natation au football américain
tous espèrent devenir une légende à part
entière
[Applaudissements]
c'est également vrai pour le soccer où
le football comme l'appelle le reste du
monde
[Applaudissements]
des légendes comme pelé maradona et
david beckham ont régné sur les terrains
pendant des années tout n'est qu'une
question de contrôle il faut réussir à
vraiment pesé sur les marchés
mais il n'y a jamais eu de rivalité
comparable que celle qui oppose les deux
joueurs de football cristiano ronaldo
cristiano est un très grand joueur
et lionel messi
[Musique]
chacun a marqué des centaines de but
et ils ont remporté le même nombre de
ballons d'or j'adore cristiano ronaldo
d'un joueur fantastique et
extraordinaire j'aime messi aussi mais
qui peut dire qui est le meilleur si on
se base sur ce qu'a gagné chacun on ne
peut pas s'en souviendra d'eux comme les
deux meilleurs joueurs de l'histoire
fondamentalement je pense que j'en ai le
messie a un talent naturel une capacité
à changer le jeu et c'est un joueur qui
travaille pour son équipe mais ronaldo
est un athlète fantastique quelqu'un de
très explosif qui peut influencer les
matches et il l'a prouvé tout au long de
sa carrière
le football de messier repose sur son
talent sa vision du jeu sa technique et
sa façon de contrôler le rythme des
matches cristiano ronaldo lui s'est
concentré sur ses dribbles et ses
feintes et sa technique pour marquer
beaucoup de buts
cristiano est agréable il continue de le
montrer avec le real madrid il n'est
jamais blessé il joue toutes les
semaines vous savez ces gars lui et
messi sont incroyables pour moi je suis
le meilleur je me moque de ce que les
gens pensent ce qu'ils disent pour moi
seulement cette année
il n'y a pas à discuter a été le
meilleur buteur de ces vingt dernières
années
et je crois qu'il peut continuer comme
ça il a toujours la volonté certaines
personnes un moment de leur vie se
disent c'est bon j'en ai fait c'est mais
lui n'en a jamais fait ça
mais pour déterminer qui est vraiment le
plus grand vous devez d'abord voir
comment ces deux là sont devenus les
légendes qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
l'argentine est un pays riche de culture
au passé politique parfois tumultueux
[Musique]
dans la province de santa fe la rivière
rosario a donné son nom à une ville où
tous les habitants considèrent messi
comme leur champion local du beau jeu
[Musique]
mais le 24 juin 1987 dans une famille
ouvrière il a vécu une enfance assez
ordinaire
son père travaille à l'usiné et sa mère
est femme de ménage
si leo messi a grandi dans une argentine
qui était économiquement instables
les parents n'avaient souvent pas assez
d'argent pour boucler leurs fins de mois
ce contexte beaucoup d'argentins se
demandaient ce ne devait pas à partir
allez à l'étranger
ces familles ces communautés était très
soudée je pense que s'ils n'étaient pas
nés tous les deux avec le talent qu'on
leur connaît ne serait sans doute pas
partie aussi loin chez eux il serait
très probablement rester vivre dans leur
ville ou dans leurs villages
dans un pays amoureux de diego maradona
le football est un mode de vie
maradona a dit c'est le futur mois
quelques joueurs argentins ont déjà
endossé ce costume nous avons connu la
victoire depuis qu'il a arrêté sa
carrière mais une des choses que si
maradona c'est que le ballon lui colle
toujours aux clients qu'ils accélèrent
presque plus vite avec le ballon est un
phénomène qu'on n'avait jamais vu
quand vous voyez ce genre de marque de
respect de mes par ses pairs et quand
vous entendez quelqu'un comme henry aux
idan c'est à dire ceux qui le disent
vous comprenez qu'ils sont exceptionnels
quand vous voyez ce que fait messi et la
façon dont il rend le jeu si simple et
élégant c'est un génie messi a suivi les
traces de ses deux frères aînés mathias
et rodrigo en rejoignant le nouvel old
boys le club de football local
faux courses de jeunes talents partir à
l'étranger pouvait leur donner une
opportunité de progresser peut-être même
de devenir footballeur professionnel
donc beaucoup de joueurs se mirent à
émigré très jeune
c'est peut-être le destin qui a fait en
sorte que messi reçoivent un maillot de
foot pour son premier anniversaire et
qu'il soit élevé par une famille de fans
de nous est ce
son père aurait été son plus grands
supporters
se considéraient comme des gens de la
classe moyenne les messies dirait qu'ils
aimaient appartenir à cette classe
moyenne de cette époque de l'argentine
où lionel était enfant
n'était pas vraiment la classe moyenne
aux 100
c'était plutôt des gens de la classe
ouvrière qui avait de l'ambition voilà
ce qu'il était à la crise en argentine a
fait qu'il était ouvert à d'autres
possibilités en fait les messi ont pensé
à partir en australie et on peut se
demander si leo messi serait devenu
footballeur s'il avait été élevé la
barre
dès ses débuts chez les new health le
plus jeune des frères messi se fit
remarquer en inscrivant quatre buts
alors qu'il n'avait que 6 ans il joue
d'anglais c'est l'illustration même du
pur gaucher il y a des fois où on ne
peut pas lui prendre le ballon
les défenseurs essaie de lui mettre des
coups de lui imposer un défi physique et
rien à faire avec l'équilibré
fantastique qu'il a le ballon mais j'ai
toujours dansé pieds
les prédispositions de messi était
indéniable tout comme son petit gabarit
sa petite taille attira l'attention d'un
recruteur de river plate et pendant une
bonne partie de son enfance c'est
quelqu'un qu'on ne croyait pas capable
de devenir footballeur professionnel à
cause de ses problèmes de croissance
la plupart pensaient qu'ils avaient un
meilleur équilibre grâce à sa petite
taille 6 ans
river plate fille pratiquer des tests
sur messi est à 11 ans on lui
diagnostique un déficit en hormone de
croissance
les dépenses de santé étaient si élevés
que river plate au moment où la crise
économique ravagé l'argentine était dans
l'incapacité de payer le traitement de
messi
aurait dépenses à ses économies pour
payer ce qu'ils ne représentaient qu'un
traitement partiel pour son fils
c'est effrayant quand on y pense parce
que vous avez deux grands joueurs
aujourd'hui peut-être les deux plus
grands footballeurs de ces vingt trente
dernières années et il aurait pu être
perdu pour le football à cause d'un
problème médical c'est aussi là une
preuve de leur volonté et leur
détermination savoir surmonter ces
obstacles pour continuer à jouer et
continuer à se surpasser comme ils l'ont
fait
de retour sur le terrain l'intérêt du
barça pour messi ne cessa de grandir ses
parents des ménagères en espagne pour se
rapprocher de la ligue a
aménagé en espagne qui a fourni les
fonds nécessaires pour payer le
traitement qui a permis à son corps de
se développer
dans un sens c'était le cocktail faro
vais être élevé dans un pays qui adore
leur football pour mais aussi qui vous
est qu arabe parce que vous n'avez pas
assez d'argent pour acheter tout ce dont
vous avez besoin et donc tout ça vous
rend plus fort mentalement vous devez
bien sûr avoir aussi du talent
le destin de mi6 a changé quand l'équipe
de barcelone l'a fait venir ici alors
qu'il était encore très jeune il a été
formé ici barcelone qui a investi dans
sa formation par sa qui a payé son
traitement hormonal quand il ne
grandissait barbe la première fois qu'il
est venu au centre il était accompagné
par ses parents on a été présenté et on
m'a demandé de lui faire la visite je
les conduis au vestiaire c'était un
garçon timide
ma première impression était que j'avais
à faire un
jeune garçon avec un corps d'enfant
mais normale
lors de son premier entretien avec les
dirigeants de l'équipe dans un
restaurant local aurait à menacer de
ramener son fils en argentine si le
barça ne le prenait pas
charles zerah ne cherche pas à savoir
sir or et bleu fait il signa
immédiatement le contrat sur une nappe
en papier
le club acceptait de signer son fils de
13 ans pour qu'il intègre son école de
foot la masia et de payer le reste du
traitement médical de messi ce qui
incluait des auto injection journalières
sa qualité principale iter
sa rapidité balle au pied avec un centre
de gravité assez bas quand on ne voit
marquer des buts aujourd'hui on parcourt
en trente à quarante mètres et un
dribble en tous ses adversaires il le
faisait déjà quand il était gamin
pendant ce temps là de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique une autre future légende
trouvait également sa voix
cristiano ronaldo dos santos aveiro plus
connu sous le diminutif de cr7 par ses
fans mais c'est à funchal une petite
ville idyllique de l'île de madère au
portugal
il est notoire que le niveau de vie là
bas n'est pas très élevé la population
est encore une fois principalement issus
de la classe ouvrière
beaucoup de gens ne quittent l'île et
cela devient un monde très oppressant il
n'y a pas tellement d'opportunités de
s'élever socialement
cela pousse une grande partie de la
jeunesse qui a frustré a tombé dans
l'alcool ou dans la drogue je pense que
le parcours de ronaldo a été marqué par
ça
ronaldo doit son nom au président
américain ronald reagan il a grandi en
jouant au football avec ses amis dans
les rues de madère
le beau jeu que ronaldo pratiquait à
l'époque n'avait pas de vrai but ils
pouvaient être interrompue à tout moment
quand une voiture faisait irruption sur
le terrain improvisé ségalen
s'entraînaient dans la rue ils
essayaient d'imiter leurs idoles de
jouer comme dans fifa il faisait tout
pour acquérir de la technique
josé le père de ronaldo encourage à son
fils alors âgé de 7 ans a joué pour le
club amateur dans d'aurignac où il
officiait en tant qu'un tendant à mi
temps
en dépit de son ignorance des règles du
football à ses débuts
ronaldo tomba amoureux de ce sport dans
lequel il découvrit à la fois la joie de
gagner et celle de voir de là fierté
dans les yeux de son père qui le
regardait depuis la touche
quand cristiano a commencé à devenir
fort à lisbonne après avoir quitté
madère à 11 ans pour aller y jouer et
même qu'il est parti à manchester united
son père n'était pas si enthousiaste que
ça il préférait rester dans son petit
monde à lui
mais c'est dans cet environnement là que
cristiano a grandi
la mère et les soeurs de ronaldo ont été
beaucoup plus difficile à convaincre car
elle ne s'intéressait pas du tout à son
nouveau passe temps
il avait trois frères et soeur et sa
mère devait s'occuper de toute la
famille donc sa mère n'était pas
disponible non plus et encore une fois m
je crois que c'était le cocktail parfait
pour qu'ils puissent devenir ce
cristiano ronaldo j'étais un enfant
spéciale si vous pouviez parler à mes
entraîneurs à mes amis à mes coéquipiers
de l'époque
il vous dirait tout ce que j'étais
spéciale
j'ai toujours pensé que je deviendrais
un joueur professionnel et que je
marquerai
il me semble être le genre d'homme qui
une fois qu'il a réussi à accomplir ce
qu'il devait faire se lancer un nouveau
challenge
je pense que ça fait partie de sa
personnalité
il cherche toujours à être motivé il me
rappelle beaucoup lebron james il veut
continuer à relever des défis c'est pas
le genre à vouloir rester tranquille
chez lui cela montre qu'ils ont quelque
chose en plus une force intérieure qui
leur permet d'aller plus loin
sa famille n'était pas à l'aise
financièrement
et ronaldo devait porter la tenue de son
frère hugo sur le terrain
mais ils se sentent est riche de l'amour
des siens quand sa famille venait le
voir jouer durant son enfance
ils ont grandi en sachant ce que
signifiait être de la classe ouvrière
parce qu'il la voyait tout autour d'eux
il voyait la vie de leurs parents de
leurs oncles et tantes
et quand ils ont eu la chance de faire
quelque chose d'autre de découvrir
d'autres horizons de gagner de l'argent
et d'avoir du succès d'être célèbre je
pense que qu'ils ont toujours garder
cela à l'esprit
sont fréquentes et de mauvaises
personnes et pris le mauvais chemin
son père était malheureux après son
retour de la guerre du mozambique
c'était un jeune homme brillant avant
d'y aller mais il en est venu briser et
est devenu alcoolique mais les jours de
la jeunesse de ronaldo était compté son
talent footballistique le propulsa
rapidement dans un style de vie d'adulte
loin de sa famille et de ses amis
ronaldo quitte à madère pour le
continent à l'âge de 11 ans afin
d'intégrer les jeunes du sporting club
de lisbonne
je pense que s'ils n'étaient pas nés
tous les deux avec ses qualités il ne
serait sans doute pas partie aussi loin
de chez eux il serait très probablement
rester vivre dans leur ville ou dans
leur village
[Musique]
ronaldo a dû partir très tôt dans ce
grand monde inconnu et découvrir de quoi
il retournait il avait sa mère avec lui
ce frère et soeur mais il est devenu un
autre homme si vos parents vous laisse
voler de vos propres ailes c'est plus
facile d'atteindre vos rêves que s'ils
veulent vous contrôlez que vous alliez à
l'école puis à l'université
mais il n'a pas connu ça rendez vous
compte à 11 ans à 11 ans il a quitté
madère pour aller à lisbonne ce qui
encore une fois représente un
gigantesque saut depuis un mois ticket
sclérosé ce que lisbonne était une ville
bien plus moderne quand vous faites ça
vous devriez quelqu'un de plus fort à 11
l'imaginer
c'était la période la plus difficile de
ma vie j'ai dû quitter ma famille à 11
ans pour aller vivre dans ce monde
complètement différent qui était
lisbonne
c'était le même pays mais ça ressemblait
à une autre partie du monde je pleurais
presque tous les jours
l'adaptation fut difficile pour ronaldo
tout était compliqué pour lui il avait
vraiment le mal du pays et ne comprenait
pas bien les différents accents des gens
du continent
je ne vais pas vous dire que qu'ils
n'ont pas eu d'enfance mais ils n'ont
pas eu une enfance normale sont partis
de chez eux à 12 et 14 ans l'un pour
aller à barcelone et l'autre pour aller
à lisbonne et à partir de là leur vie
ont été happés par les footballs
par ces fabriques de footballeur cette
industrie du football et ce afin
d'emmener ses deux fantastiques talent
là où ils devaient se retrouver
alors que la vie en dehors du terrain
était compliqué les performances de
ronaldo commencèrent à se remarquer tant
il surclassait ses homologues
vous saviez forcément que ronaldo était
dans les parages c'est un showman il
veut que les gens du monde entier sache
où il est et ce qui fait le
gêne d'être au centre de toutes les
attentions mais le plus souvent il est
bien trop heureux de poser sur la plage
de voir ses photos dans les magazines
glamour cristiano ronaldo a besoin
d'être vu c'est un joueur très malin un
attaquant fantastique très agile avec le
ballon ce qui lui manquait peut-être
c'était de muscler un peu son jeu et
puis il a eu ses ennuis de santé
alors qu'il avait 15 ans le rêve de
ronaldo a failli s'envoler quand on lui
a diagnostiqué une arythmie cardiaque un
problème qui lorsqu'il n'est pas traité
s'est déjà révélée fatale pour certains
athlètes ronaldo a été opéré avec succès
et a ainsi pu remettre sa carrière de
footballeur sur les rails
ce qu'ils sont devenus tous les deux
peut-être à l'image de leur carrière
elles ont explosé parce que ronaldo est
à présent un monstre physique c'est un
sprinteur mais aussi un homme capable de
courir sur de longues distances on n'a
probablement jamais vu un joueur prenant
autant soin de son physique et faisant
autant attention à la dimension physique
de son sport que cristiano ronaldo avant
l'âge de 16 ans ronaldo s'était déjà
fait remarquer dans le monde du football
en devenant le premier joueur de
l'histoire du sporting a joué dans
l'équipe des moins de 16 ans des moins
de 17 ans en réserve des moins de 18 ans
et en équipe première dans la même
saison e l'autre raison qui l'a fait
sortir du lourd c'était qu'à chaque fois
qu'il recevait le ballon il jouait
presque comme comme le plus grand dans
les cours de récré il prenait le ballon
et ils foncé tout droit dans la défense
de manchester united il continuer
jusqu'à ce qu'il perde à chaque fois il
ne faisait jamais de passe ne vais
jamais la tête il ne faisait que courir
mais comme il était très talentueux on
ne pouvait pas souvent lui prendre le
ballon
au cours de la saison 2002 2003 ronaldo
attira l'attention de soeur alex
ferguson lors d'un match amical disputé
au portugal entre manchester united et
le sporting club de lisbonne
je ne vais pas vous dire que tous les
spectateurs dans le stade savait qu'il
voyait une superstar parce que ce serait
faux mais le voyez quelqu'un se
démarquer et après le match dans les
vestiaires les joueurs de manchester
united ont dit à sa soeur alex ferguson
ces mecs contre lequel on vienne jouer
il faut le faire signer
ferguson et ses joueurs ont été si
impressionné par le jeune ronaldo de 17
ans qu'il le court teaser tout de suite
après le match
performance attira l'attention de tous
ceux qui étaient étroitement lié à
manchester united
et ferguson avant ça le transfert d'un
lieu il savait qu arsenal et liverpool
était intéressé il s'est dit qu'après ce
mage secret n'en était plus un et qu'il
fallait le faire signer et le faire
signer tout de suite il est donc devenu
un joueur de manchester très rapide ce
jour là quand la majorité des membres
dont manchester united l'a vu pour la
première fois il a purement et
simplement gagner sa place au sein de
l'équipe
c'était un bon match un bon entraînement
on a joué contre une bonne équipe et
j'ai pris du plaisir à jouer aujourd'hui
manchester united paya un montant record
de 12 millions de livres pour son
transfert ronaldo devint le tout premier
joueur portugais a signé pour le club
cette évidence ronaldo a reçu le don
d'être un showman
il se complaisait dans son personnage du
mec qui veut être le meilleur le plus
beau la star dès son plus jeune âge
quand il est arrivé à manchester il
s'intéressait au style de coiffure
branché et aux chaussures et à son
bronzage autant qu'à son football certes
il a vite appris les ficelles du métier
au début il faisait trop d'acrobaties
trop de passements de jambes maintenant
il ne joue les matchs que le mieux
possible et de la manière la plus
efficace et ça ça témoigne de sa
capacité à apprendre le football pour
cristiano le passage à manchester united
a été cruciale ces temps sont présents
là bas qu'il est devenu un vrai
compétiteur il peut marquer de la tête
il tire de deux pieds il a travaillé
énormément pour gagner en vitesse et en
puissance à
l'arrivée de ronaldo à manchester united
suscita beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
d'excitation mais malheureusement le
petit nouveau débuta sa carrière sur le
banc cependant à la 60e minute du match
d'ouverture qui opposait manchester à
bolton
ronaldo fit ses débuts en première ligue
en remplaçant un de ses coéquipiers
il occupe une position presque unique
dans le coeur de manchester united
alex ferguson son entraîneur se montra
décisif dans l'évolution de ronaldo qui
n'était pas encore imperméable à
l'adversité
pendant la première saison de ronaldo
avec le club ferguson fille pleurait
cristiano après un mauvais match dix ans
à son jeune joueur pour qui tu te prends
en essayant de jouer si égoïstement tu
ne deviendra jamais un joueur si tu fais
ça avec le temps ronaldo prouvera qu'il
avait bel et bien retenu la leçon
je me souviens que parfois quand on
avait mal joué on avait perdu des
matches
qu'il mettait des coups de pied dans les
gestes dans les chaussures donc tout ce
qu'il y avait l'eau les poissons
il était tout rouge
aurait dû passer le ballon c'était
incroyable mais c'était bien et c'était
toujours le premier arrivé est toujours
le dernier à rentrer chez lui j'ai donc
appris ce genre de choses à son contact
lorsque ronaldo arrive sur le terrain
d'ailleurs vous avez qu il entre
toujours en dernier
genre c'est bon le match peut commencer
je suis là vous dites ok montre moi
comme tu es bon et lui de vous répondre
ça marche regarde ce qu'ils regardent
cette tête et là je dribble quatre ou
cinq joueurs
je pense que messi s'imbrique dans le
jeu il est emporté ronaldo lui dit qu'il
a des choses à prouver il est dans
l'adversité je vais vous montrer à quel
point suivant
même si c'est un joueur individuel et
qu'il peut décider de prendre le match à
son compte il est conscient qu'il n'est
pas tout seul qu'il y à beaucoup
d'autres joueurs sur le terrain
cristiano ronaldo c'est tout le
contraire
cristiano c'est un buteur animal la
différence entre ronaldo et les autres
jeunes recrues c'est que lui quand il
était sur le terrain il devenait un
guerrier il prenait un coup il se
relevait il en prenait un autre il se
relevait encore et puis il marqué un but
et ça lui suffisait c'était tout ce qui
comptait l'optimisme ne pouvait que
s'amplifier au tour de manchester united
et de l'étoile montante du sport il ne
ressemblait pas aux autres joueurs de
l'équipe il était grand il était bronzé
aux uv il avait des boucles d'oreilles
il portait une sorte de sac à main mais
ça n'avait pas d'importance pour eux
parce qu'il venait d'un milieu
similaires la classe ouvrière il avait
la volonté et il voulait travailler dur
et ils ont jugé sur ce qui compte c'est
à dire un entraînement et pendant les
matchs du samedi après-midi avec ronaldo
tout est une question de puissance
rythme de but marqué dgo du produit
final de l'ensemble de ceux qui la
portent sur le terrain
il est devenu une icône du sport mondial
ce qui est assez rare dans le football
on a plus l'habitude de voir des stars
du golf les stars du basket ou de la nfl
mais ces gars là sont maintenant des
icônes mondiales
pendant ces années l'équipe de
manchester united a connu à la fois la
joie de gagner et l'agonie de la défaite
mais il y aura encore beaucoup plus de
hauts et de bas au cours de la carrière
légendaire de ronaldo avec les red
devils
ronaldo est un fumeur de première vous
savez au début de sa carrière il se
souciait de son look sa coupe de cheveux
ses chaussures colorées comme il se
souciait de son football avec ses trop
nombreux gestes techniques au fil du
temps il a appris à comment dire à
enterrer ce désir presque instinctif de
faire le show sur le terrain avec tous
ces gestes technique des battements de
jambes pour simplement jouer les matchs
le mieux possible en exploitant au mieux
sa virtuosité sa possession de balle et
ses positions sur le terrain il a une
morphologie différente très sculptural
il est vraiment impressionnante quand il
court il a l'air de pouvoir traverser un
mur de briques en courant sans le sentir
il a travaillé très dur pour obtenir son
physique pour lui permettre de sauter
plus haut que n'importe qui pourra voir
une accélération meilleur que n'importe
qui pour être en mesure d'avoir un corps
très athlétique très puissant ce qu'il
est parvenu à faire en faisant beaucoup
de musculation
oui la faiblesse plus l'exploitera il
marquera ronaldo est devenu un joueur
exceptionnel
mais si l'aîné dans une équipe dans une
philosophie avec johan cruijff et avec
pep guardiola on va jouer de cette façon
c'est comme ça que tu joues on va te
préparer à ce style de football et on va
transformer ce style de football en
fonction de ce que tu peux faire c'était
donc une sorte de mariage idéal en fait
ici est heureux à barcelone ça colle
bien c'est comme sa famille au cours des
années suivantes messi s'est épanoui
grandissant hors et sur le terrain où il
a rapidement gravi les échelons depuis
les juniors il joue encore pour le
plaisir ça se voit sur son visage ils
adorent le football on ne peut pas lui
prendre le ballon il se faufile il
zigzague comme s'ils étaient programmés
par un ordinateur à 17 ans messi fait
ses débuts professionnels lors de la
saison 2004 2005 devenant ainsi le
deuxième plus jeune joueur à rentrer sur
le terrain avec l'équipe première de
barcelone c'est un animal de nos jeux un
aspect si simple et gracieux c'est de la
poésie quand il joue vous êtes comme
devant un spectacle de ballet ne manque
plus que la musique il était au meilleur
endroit c'était le club qui gagne est le
plus de trophées il marquait les plus
beaux buts vivez dans un pays magnifique
gagner plus d'argent qu'ils n'en avaient
jamais rêvé il n'avait aucune raison de
partir aucune sauf s'il était rentré en
argentine pour y jouer ce qu'il fera
probablement à la fin de sa carrière
mais il n'allait pas le faire alors
qu'il était au top en effet les rêves de
l'adolescent messi était devenu réalité
[Applaudissements]
vous devenez une personne plus forte
vous avez besoin de ça pour devenir
messi ou de venir ronaldo tous les
observateurs du football 10 comme ici
est meilleur que tenait ou meilleure que
cruijff ou meilleur que maradona
barrettes de mémoire mais je ne connais
personne
efface vraiment ce que fait messi
semaine après semaine avec le ballon
gagnant presque toutes les récompenses
individuelles imaginables ronaldo a
porté ses coéquipiers à ses côtés
pendant son ascension fulgurante alors
que manchester united remporté deux
coupes de la ligue anglaise et trois
championnats d'angleterre
il répète souvent qu'il considère alex
ferguson comme son père dans le football
et il l'a aidé à réaliser les aspects
physique du football allait de pair avec
le talent indéniable qu'il avait déjà
je pense que les vrais amoureux de ce
jeu se réfère essentiellement à ses 2 à
espérons que ça continue longtemps
profitons-en parce que ça ne durera pas
éternellement
avec un bilan affichant pas moins de 118
buts et 292 apparition en six saisons la
carrière de cristiano ronaldo à
manchester united s'est déroulée comme
un conte de fées
mais la star de la compétition en veut
plus il voyait bien que ronaldo en fait
des tonnes il savait qu'il voulait être
la vedette des spectacles mais il était
la vedette du spectacle
ronaldo aurait pu quitter le club encore
plus tôt s'il n'avait pas eu sa relation
étroite avec ferguson
avoir le coeur brisé
tout en acceptant
c'est toujours comme ça à la fin d'une
relation quand on sait qu'il faut se
séparer parce que c'est la meilleure
chose à faire mais quand même temps
c'est douloureux c'était un peu la même
chose
véritable titans du monde du football
ferguson a soutenu son joueur sur le
plan émotionnel lorsque le père de
ronaldo est mort d'une maladie liée à
l'alcool
cristiano avait 20 ans
son père était alcoolique un des
souvenirs d'enfance de ronaldo et
d'avoir fait sortir son père d'un bar
ivre parce qu'il ne pouvait pas dormir
quand on n'était pas là
mon père était à londres et il était
très malade il était entré d'urgence à
l'hôpital j'ai été voir le coach et je
lui ai dit je me sens pas bien j'ai
besoin d'aller voir mon père cristiano
tu veux y aller un jour deux jours une
semaine
vas-y tu vas me manquer tu vas nous
manquer ici parce que tu es important
mais notre papa passe avant tout
[Musique]
malgré son affection pour son entraîneur
le jeune homme de 24 ans était prêt à
relever un nouveau défi il signe au real
madrid en 2009 pour la somme record de
94 millions d'euros ce qui fait de lui à
l'époque le joueur le plus cher de
l'histoire
c'est pourquoi je pense que dans la tête
de ronaldo il finira avec le real madrid
de la meilleure façon en gagnant la
ligue des champions trois fois de suite
c'est plus ils partirent à relever un
nouveau défi
j'espère que ce sera ici aux etats-unis
pour incarner cette marque ce marché et
avoir le même genre d'impact que beckham
a pu avoir c'est la façon dont cela
s'est passé il n'y avait pas de rancoeur
il n'y avait pas de colère comme c'est
souvent le cas chaque fois que ronaldo
retourne à old trafford il est traité
comme un héros de retour
parce que
lorsqu'il aura donné énormément et ce
pendant une période importante
aujourd'hui encore les supporters de
manchester united ont une place spéciale
dans leur coeur pour le buteur portugais
les deux stars sont non seulement rival
sur le terrain mais elles peuvent aussi
se mesurer l'une à l'autre vis-à-vis des
sponsors et autres activités
commerciales beaucoup de gars vont à la
gestion et à l'encadrement ils ont
encore quelque chose à prouver à la fin
de leur carrière de joueur ils ont une
raison d'aller plus loin et d'en faire
plus quelles raisons ces deux gars-là
aurait de faire quoi que ce soit ils
n'ont absolument plus rien à prouver
nous avons examiné les parcours qu'ils
ont fait pour devenir les légendes
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
voici une comparaison des statistiques
de ronaldo et de messier il suffirait de
regarder les deux joueurs côte à côte
pour penser que ronaldo dispose d'un
léger avantage sur messi mais ce n'est
pas forcément vrai messi est un génie
naturel
quand on regarde ronaldo on sait qu'il a
travaillé pour être un génie alors
qu'avec mais si on voit que celui vient
naturellement pour moi messi n'est pas
humain et cristiano est le meilleur d
humeur quand messi veut gagner vous
n'avez aucune chance il va aller voir le
gardien et lui dire passe moi la balle
c'est la force de barcelone donc s'il
doit aller jusqu'au bout doit passer
yaya touré éventuellement ou boosket
sous google ou rafa marquez qui que ce
soit qui joue
et ça fait 1 0 ronaldo mesure 1 m 87
tandis que messi est bien plus petit à
un mètre soixante dix mais leur carrure
sont similaires
ronaldo était beaucoup plus mince quand
il a commencé mais il a rapidement pris
du muscle en raison des entraînements
rigoureux du sporting club de lisbonne
puis de manchester united
cependant c'est dans leur style de jeu
qu'ils montrent leur domination sur le
terrain dans le football finalement
c'est comme dans tous les sports et des
gens qui aiment les joueurs qui sont
plus agressifs qu'ils sont plus rapides
ou qui ont un plus beau corps et
d'autres qui préfèrent des joueurs plus
élégant sur terrain plus technique
les jeunes joueurs du monde entier
s'entraîne jour et nuit pour imiter leur
mouvement messi est réputé pour ses
mouvements rapides aussi bien à travers
les défenseurs qu'à travers les joueurs
du milieu de terrain sa conduite de
balle est inégalée il utilise son centre
de gravité très bas ainsi que des
feintes de corps irréel et son talents
de dribbleur hors norme pour hacher menu
ses opposants et aller marquer de
n'importe où dans la surface de
réparation
avec lui si vous savez comment revenir
au pied mais sa conduite de balle avec
son centre de gravité bas sa qualité de
joueur de passes il a mis des joueurs
internationaux sur le dos rien qu'en
courant avec eux vous ne pouvez pas là
si vous lui donnez un coup pour lui
prendre le ballon cela vous ridiculisera
encore plus il a longtemps joué comme
deuxième attaquant jusqu'à ce qu'il
change sa position mais quand il
arrivait sur terrain monde tous les
joueurs se disaient ils arrivent leo
messi arrive danger
[Musique]
ronaldo a lui aussi plus d'un tour dans
son sac
le sultan du passement de jambes fait en
sorte que le découpage de l'adversaire
ressemble à un jeu d'enfant sur le
terrain devant les cages il domine
marquer des buts est une seconde nature
pour cet athlète il peut marquer sur
coup franc et avec un tir de l'extérieur
de la surface qu'il s'agisse d'une
bicyclette parfaitement synchronisé d'un
sombrero
ou d'une puissante tête
cet attaquant phénoménale est un
adversaire redouté sur n'importe quel
terrain pour ce qui est de leur palmarès
et bien c'est à peu près la même chose
chacun compte 4 soulier d'or quatre
titres en ligue des champions et cinq
ballons d'or la plus prestigieuse des
récompenses individuelles
sont égaux lorsqu'il s'agit de victoire
elle cela ne veut rien dire parce que
sur une année l'un peut faire mieux pire
que l'autre chacun peut avoir marqué
plus ou moins de buts gagner plus ou
moins de récompenses semaine définit pas
qui est le meilleur maintenant qu'ils
sont tous les deux dans la liga
espagnole est fermement ancré dans leurs
clubs respectifs
messi à barcelone ronaldo au real madrid
leur rivalité est passé un niveau
supérieur bien sûr il y à d'autres
équipes dans le monde entier avec des
rivalités importantes au sein de leur
ligue manchester united et manchester
city chelsea et arsenal mais vous pouvez
vous attendre à ce que les supporters
espagnols prennent un jour de congé pour
encourager leur équipe favorite lorsque
le barça et le real se retrouvent face à
face
ronaldo s'est épanoui au real madrid
gagnant non seulement le coeur des
supporters madrilènes mais aussi le
respect de ses coéquipiers
de son côté messi est devenu le héros de
barcelone et les fans l'adorent
il est le leader tacite de l'équipe
faisant la une des journaux après chaque
victoire en championnat et chaque but
exceptionnel
on a toujours entendu parler d'offre qui
amènerait messi a quitté un jour cette
terre sacrée
mais cela reste encore à voir
en plein coeur de barcelone vous
trouverez un restaurant qui ressemble à
première vue à de nombreux restaurants
du centre ville
entrez et vous découvrirez que l'un des
rêves d'enfance de messi est devenu
réalité
[Musique]
la famille de messi chercher une
référence pour ouvrir un restaurant et
c'est
ce qui est différent dans ce concept
c'est que c'est un restaurant pour tout
le monde pour venir en famille pour des
hommes d'affaires pour des réunions des
congrès
c'est un nouveau concept comme celui
d'un village vous avez par exemple juste
à l'entrée du restaurant une mini
boucherie charcuterie tout à fait
typique de l'espagne on trouve ce genre
de petites boutiques dans n'importe quel
village vous avez un salon de coiffure
et le bar du village comme celui que
nous avons maintenant et nous avons un
jeu de tir au but juste ici avec les
t-shirts de messi et suarez c'est
incroyable et nous avons l'église nous
avons tout ce qu'on trouve sur une place
de village à chaque table où vous vous
asseyez dans le restaurant vous
recommande toujours de partager avec un
plat au milieu où tout le monde se sert
comme dans un village comme quand vous
allez au bar avec vos amis et y en a un
qui prend une bière à l'autre une
sangria et l'autre encore un bon verre
de vin
nous sommes ici avec monica morales chef
cuisinier rebelle à vista et elle va
nous préparer un super cela bonjour
monica qu'est ce que tu veux nous
préparer nous en séparer une tartelette
aux tourteaux la base est un mélange de
miettes de tourteaux avec de la sauce
tartare elle sera recouverte avec un
avocat découpé en fleurs sur lequel il y
aura une vinaigrette les échalotes et
des arômes ceci s'appelle pasta philo
c'est une pâte faite de couches
extrêmement fine on les juxtaposer on
met un peu d'huile et on les colle avec
du blanc d'oeuf
nous avons la pasta philo
c'est la sauce tartare mélangés aux
tourteaux et on retrouvera avec
l'avocate
en fait ce sont des saveurs que nous
avons tous en mémoire
le nap donc avec un peu des souvenirs de
notre enfance je vois
la pression ça me donne l'impression de
manger les plaques préparer ma mère que
préparer ma grand mère
ça ressemble à un terrain de football
comme si on était
je n'avais jamais pensé que j'aurais le
plaisir de goûter le deuxième plat le
plus commandé hop et la vista
doit le couper en une seule fois n'est
ce pas la tradition veut qu'on le coupe
en une seule fois voyons si j'y arrive
oh mon dieu c'est vraiment délicieux
quelquefois les gens viennent avec le
tee shirt de barcelone parce qu'ils vont
ou ont été à un match il entre dans le
restaurant et il demande messi est là et
jeudi il n'est pas encore arrivé
ici est le propriétaire non pas le
gérant alors je vais plus loin dans la
blague et je leur dis mais je vais
l'appeler ou vu envoyer un message pour
qu'il tienne plainte ou au restaurant
vous apporter le dessert à votre table
tout comme messi ronaldo s'essaye aussi
à la restauration
tatel situé à madrid est une
coentreprise qu'il a commencé avec son
copain rafael nadal mais pour ronaldo
son sens aigu des affaires ne s'arrête
pas à la restauration
sa marque cr7 se vend partout dans le
monde
sa marque représente vraiment un choix
classique élégant à porter tous les
jours dans chaque mec a besoin il
investit dans tout dans ces hôtels
prestigieux à lisbonne et dans son île
natale de madère dans de nombreux
parfums et dans une ligne de vêtements
et de sous vêtements de luxe
c'est vraiment comme dans un rêve
ce qui m'est arrivé dans ma vie ces dix
dernières années
j'ai fait énormément de choses mais
sentir ce parfum pour moi c'est
incroyable parce que c'est quelque chose
que j'utilise tous les jours un gain qui
regarde toutes ses différentes marques
et qui fait le choix d'acheter toutes
ces marques produites par ronaldo est un
gars qu'il admire et qui veut peut-être
renforcer sa confiance en lui
je crois qu ronaldo est le plus
exhibitionniste des deux
reste yano ronaldo a une personnalité
très forte être le centre de l'attention
c'est un garçon qui n'a pas peur de la
pression même bugatti a placé un cr7 sur
l'un de ses nouveaux modèles en
l'honneur de la star du football
et on n'a pas parlé de ces très très
nombreux parrainage
messi est beaucoup plus discret pourrait
même dire réservés alors que ronaldo est
plus exubérant et helios cristiano est
un joueur qui aime beaucoup par année
parce qu'il a un corps que tous les
hommes envie qu'il ressemble à un
mannequin de mode c'est quelque chose
que les marques savent
il a plus de sponsors que leo messi
messi est un joueur qui a plus les pieds
sur terre pour les marques bien sûr
c'est quelqu'un d'intéressant mais c'est
une personne beaucoup plus introverti
beaucoup plus famille pour en revenir
aux contrats de parrainage ronaldo et
messi ne se limite pas à afficher le nom
de leur propre restaurant et produit des
entreprises multi milliardaire se
battent littéralement à mort pour
obtenir des contrats de parrainage de
ces deux légendes par exemple tous deux
sont très présents sur des compagnies
aériennes sur divers équipements
sportifs et sur des suppléments
nutritionnels
de plus il ne faut pas oublier les jeux
vidéo on ne peut pas trouver de jeux
fifa sans ces deux là
n'ont ronaldo est un produit de luxe
messi est un produit qui donne des
aspirations là où ronaldo vendu
champagne français mais s'il vend du
soda à l'orangé en amérique latine
tout les fan de messi ont pris le bus
pour aller au stade après avoir
économisé longtemps pour pouvoir acheter
leurs billets les fans de ronaldo ils
vont au stade en voiture et leurs
parkings et déjà payés
ronaldo va séduire un homme de 65 ans
qui rêve de ce qu'il aurait pu être
quand il avait 10 ans
en dehors du terrain ronaldo et messi
attire toujours l'attention de ses fans
et de la presse particulièrement quand
on en vient à leur sens du style
on peut voir une forte opposition entre
le style vestimentaire de ronaldo et
celui de messi comme quand ils sont sur
le terrain avec mais si on a un style de
vie beaucoup plus cool comme de porter
des tennis ordinaire
avec ronaldo c'est le luxe tout le temps
partout des formes des couleurs très
voyante des choses beaucoup plus tape à
l'oeil
les signatures de messi et de ronaldo ne
s'arrête pas à leur propre garde-robe
elles sont aussi significatif pour bien
d'autres choses
ronaldo a très certainement eu sa part
de liaison prestigieuse très récemment
avec le super mannequin irina shayk est
aujourd'hui avec georgina rodriguez
georgina n'est pas seulement la mère de
leur fille née récemment elle a eu une
carrière de mannequin et a travaillé
comme associé chez gucci pour être avec
ronaldo il vaut mieux mettre votre
propre sens du style à la page
ronaldo est un brillant spécialiste du
marketing il a vraiment pris ce que dieu
lui a donnée et puis la transformer en
une entreprise aux pouvoirs
extraordinaires et ça il a bien ri
il a un fils et deux magnifiques béni
des dieux il fait tout ce qu'il fait
très bien il est vraiment le meilleur
ses vêtements sont toujours très bien
taillé la plupart du temps on le voit en
veste mais ce ne sera pas forcément un
blazer bien sûr il porte aussi de beaux
costumes on le voit aussi souvent avec
une veste en cuir superbes ce sont
toujours de superbes matière ou quelque
chose vous savez avec des fermetures
éclair beaucoup de détails ces choses
qui représente beaucoup d'argent la
célébrité n'est pas que dans les
vêtements que l'on porte mais dans
chaque aspect de son apparence et quand
il s'agit de ronaldo il ne surveille pas
seulement son physique ses soins pour la
peau sont aussi une priorité absolue
c'est l'un des pré séries de ronaldo et
c'est un excellent hydratant entier h
pour hommes il a ce bel aspect lisse il
apaise le feu du rasoir il génial pour
les peaux sensibles et surtout il aide à
réduire les rides qui inquiète tout à
chacun
c'est pourquoi ronaldo a l'air parfait
c'est la même chose pour messi désormais
mariée à son amour d'enfance antonella
roccuzzo le style d'antonella fait aussi
les gros titres quand messi antonella se
sont finalement dit oui la mariée s'est
assuré que sa robe allait aussi faire la
une
cette lara est une entreprise située à
barcelone ont mis sa ligne nous sommes
dans le design de robes de mariées
d'europe
et nous sommes dans plus de 70 pays
notre relation avec antonella dure déjà
depuis de longues années pratiquement
depuis qu'elle est arrivée en espagne
mauvais nous l'avons accompagné dans
quasiment tous ces moments spéciaux
[Musique]
pour son mariage avec leo messi nous lui
avons faite de robes ou non une pour la
cérémonie et une autre pour la soirée
plus confortable et plus pratique pour
danser
en ce qui concerne la robe de mariée
éblouissante de la femme de messi
je pense que ça en dit beaucoup sur
leurs coûts
on comprend que pour lui il n'ya rien de
trop beau pour elle lorsque vous êtes
marié à une personnalité sportive
internationale vous pouvez parier que
votre mariage fera la une des journaux
et dans le cas de messi qu'il bloquera
toute la ville il s'est marié en
argentine la moitié du pays a été
pratiquement bloqué faut dire qu'il est
vraiment considéré comme un roi à la
bartère mais surtout en termes de
sécurité je pense que c'est nécessaire
c'est un moment spécial c'est le jour le
plus important pour lui et pour sa femme
et je ne voudrais pas d'hélico qui
volent autour si j'étais eux je ne
voudrais pas de paparazzi à l'affût dans
les buissons la sécurité est primordiale
où qu'ils aillent leur statut de
célébrité les précèdent et les suit que
ce soit pour dîner dehors un soir ou
pour des vacances en famille
p diddy a dit plus on a d'argent plus on
a un problème et ce qui est absolument
vrai pour les gens célèbres puis ils ont
d'argent puis ils deviennent populaires
mois ils ont d'intimité et moins il mène
une vie normale tout à fait logique de
dire çà doit être merveilleux d'être
cristiano ronado parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'argent il est célèbre et du succès
mais il fait beaucoup de sacrifices
prennent pas dehors il est enfermé dans
une bulle
ce n'est que justice de dire quand les
moments que je vis aujourd'hui que
l'endroit où je suis maintenant n'est
pas l'endroit où j'avais toujours rêvé
d'être
quelquefois je
je préfère dire que c'est la vie
parfaite dont j'ai toujours rêvé parce
que je ne peux pas me
vous savez une reçoivent souvent de
nombreuses critiques parce qu'ils
dépensent des sommes astronomiques en
vacances quand il loue ses yachts quand
ils privatisent ses hôtels et foncer
chose dont les gens disent whaou
pourquoi doivent-ils dépenser tout leur
argent là dedans mais en réalité à ce
moment là ils sont juste en train de
chercher un peu d'intimité
ce qui est clair c'est que quand il
entre sur un terrain c'est un être
humain extraordinaire c'est un martien
il vient d'une autre planète
mais dès qu'il sort de ce vaste
rectangle c'est juste un gars normal
malki qui a besoin qu'on s'occupe de lui
qui a besoin de gens autour de lui qui
le protège
donc bien souvent ils attirent une foule
sans le joueur se retrouve un lieu et
s'en éloigne plus vite
hélas il n'est pas question d'argent de
réseaux sociaux de photo ni vidéo
ça fait partie du boulot je dois
respecter ça il faut vendre il faut
faire de l'argent
bien que leurs contrats commerciaux
rapporte vraiment de grosses sommes tout
cet argent ne reste pas dans leurs
comptes en banque et ne sert pas qu'à
payer de luxueuses vacances
cette famille essayer de recueillir de
l'argent pour leurs tristes qui a une
forme rare de cancer du cerveau et à des
convulsions tous les jours il lui en
demander alors s'il pouvait donner un
peu maillot et une jolie paire de
crampons pour qu'ils puissent essayer de
récolter un peu d'argent ils avaient
besoin de 83 mille dollars pour
l'opération chirurgicale de l'enfant
alors que ce qu'il a fait il a dit ok je
vous donnerai ça et je vais aller plus
loin je paierai la totalité des fonds
une grande partie des revenus de messi
et de ronaldo va à des associations
caritatives
tous deux ont donné des millions de
dollars à des oeuvres de charité tels
que l'unicef et la fondation make a wish
et ce n'est pas seulement une question
de chèques à remplir pour ces deux
superstars ces deux là sont très
attentifs au monde malgré tout leur
pouvoir tous les honneurs qu'ils
reçoivent ils font beaucoup et donne
beaucoup
pour la fondation de messi sait
construire des salles de classe dans une
scierie déchiré par la guerre pour
ronaldo sait donner son sang il est
certain qu'ils peuvent faire la
différence rien qu'avec l'argent qu'ils
donnent tous deux s'implique réellement
quand on regarde les sommes d'argent
qu'ils consacrent aux oeuvres de charité
ils ont un véritable engagement
personnel et leurs fans ont une grande
importance pour eux
cristiano est très présent dans les
médias ce qui pourrait être une arme à
double tranchant mais en même temps
qu'il nous montre une partie de sa vie
personnelle où il nous montre sa maison
ses voitures ses voyages ses entreprises
il nous montre aussi sa générosité à
travers son implication dans ces oeuvres
de charité
c'est une personne qui donne tous les
mois il a donné beaucoup d'argent pour
enrayer les incendies au portugal
personne ne dit du mal de cristiano
parce que cristiano a investi beaucoup
pour son pays et sa population
il se passe la même chose avec leo messi
il a une fondation avec plus de
cinquante antennes à travers le monde ce
sont des gens qui ont beaucoup mais qui
donne aussi
l'alliance de leur incroyable talent sur
le terrain et de la taille de leur coeur
accentue l'influencent que ces deux
légendes ont dans le monde
aujourd'hui les sportifs sont très
importants ont eu marre ils sont des
icônes les modèles pour les jeunes et
pour la société en général je pense que
ces deux là ne sont pas perdus dans des
soirées trop arrosées des scandales rien
de tout ça
on les connaît que comme joueur de foot
messi et cristiano ne sont connus que
pour ça et pour avoir une vie tranquille
avec leur famille leurs enfants leurs
amis et leur entourage proche
[Musique]
alors que ronaldo et messi ont gagné
tant de récompenser le championnat il
est difficile de comprendre pourquoi la
coupe du monde est si importante
ils ont toujours eu cette volonté de
s'améliorer les statistiques dirait que
tous deux embarquent des bus ont gagné
des trophées le ballon d'or ils ont été
élus meilleurs joueurs d'europe ils sont
très semblables je crois que ça va être
difficile pour tout le monde
et je pense que l'argentine est bien
placé pour faire de belles choses cette
année et que nous pourrions bien
atteindre notre objectif
pour la coupe du monde c'est étrange
parce que chacun d'eux a été la star
mondiale le meilleur joueur du monde en
plus depuis 2008 ils se partagent le
titre de meilleur joueur de l'année est
cependant aucun d'eux n'a réussi à
élever son niveau de football jusqu'à
gagner une coupe du monde
il adorerait tous les deux gagné la
coupe du monde cela signifie tellement
c'est un sport d'équipé
mais chacun d'eux voudrait
personnellement être celui qui offre la
coupe du monde à son pays
pour n'importe quelle étoile du foot la
coupe du monde est fondamentale on se
hisse au niveau des plus grands joueurs
de l'histoire stefano pelé maradona
cruijff
chacun d'eux a tenté sa chance plusieurs
fois à cet événement planétaire et ni
l'un ni l'autre n'a réussi à remporter
la victoire tant convoité wang quand
vous perdez une grande compétition quand
vous n'y arrivez pas avec votre groupe
ce que ce soit l'équipe nationale ou le
real madrid ou autre
ça c'est vraiment les moments les plus
compliquées quand vous perdez quand vous
ne gagnez pas une finale de monstres là
c'est le pire
c'est dommage que ces deux joueurs
n'aient pas eu tout au long de leur
carrière de meilleure équipe nationale
bien que portugal et gagner le
championnat d'europe
pour ronaldo son équipe nationale a
peiné pour passer les premiers tours à
un certain moment les tensions était si
forte qu'il s'est même accrochée avec
son coéquipier de manchester united
wayne rooney
c'est ce qui s'est passé pendant la
coupe du monde 2006 quand il est évident
que rooney a été sorti de façon
discutable et que ronaldo était impliqué
dans la sphère on cette histoire
incroyable quand l'angleterre a été
sorti de la coupe du monde vous avez ces
deux gars qui joue pour le club le plus
fort le plus célèbre et le plus
victorieux qui s'accrochent aux yeux de
tous le monde entier regarde une
histoire fantastique
rétrospectivement tels que ça s'est
passé ça a fait beaucoup de bruit pour
rien
la vérité c'est que ronaldo et rooney tu
dirais pas qu'ils sont proches il existe
entre eux une certaine affection est
très certainement un respect mutuel pour
messi l'histoire est un peu différente
l'argentine est l'une des équipes les
plus fortes dans la coupe du monde
c'est sa meilleure occasion il a montré
au cours des éliminatoires que le pays
avait besoin de lui
cependant l'équipe de messi a reçu un
coup terrible en perdant contre
l'allemagne lors de la coupe du monde
que l'on dise qu'un joueur comme messi a
besoin d'une victoire en coupe du monde
pour être le meilleur me semble ridicule
il n'a pas besoin de gagner avec la
sélection nationale pour qu'on le
considère comme le plus grand de
l'histoire pour moi il l'est c'est la
même chose dans le cas de ronaldo il
sera arrivé la même chose s'il n'avait
pas gagné la coupe d'europe l'année
dernière avec sa sélection
je crois que c'est très important pour
eux de sentir qu'ils mènent leur pays à
la victoire comme l'ont fait maradona et
pelé alors
lionel messi y est presque arrivé en
2010 mais il a déçu en quart de finale
contre l'allemagne alors qu'il était là
pour gagner la coupe du monde et qu'il
pouvait mener sont payés à la victoire
finalement il ne l'a pas fait et ronaldo
non plus avec le portugal
il se peut bien que la coupe du monde
reste toujours insaisissable pour
ronaldo comme pour messi à mesure qu'ils
avancent dans leur carrière leur chance
de gagner la coupe du monde diminue
aussi
en argentine avec moi si c'est un peu
comme s'il quittait un âge d'or parce
qu'il a disputé une finale de coupe du
monde 2 finale de copa america il en a
même joué une troisième encore ensuite
c'est donc qui lui manque juste un petit
rien pour gagner la coupe ce qui dans 20
30 ans regarderont en arriérés du roi
mais messi n'a pas gagné la coupe du
monde cela ça voudra dire qu'ils n'ont
rien compris à ce qu'est messi messi il
est bien au delà d'une coupe du monde
messi est allé à deux finales en
amérique du sud et les a perdus tous les
deux donc la coupe du monde en russie
sera probablement la dernière occasion
de le voir en compétition ou plus haut
niveau il adorerait s'affronter sur la
scène il adorerait être le personnage
principal unir leurs forces pour
conduire leur pays à la gloire de la
coupe du monde savoir si l'un ou l'autre
sera capable de faire ça reste à
débattre je ne suis pas tout à fait sûr
que ni l'argentine ni le portugal n'est
les meilleures équipes ou les meilleurs
entraîneurs pour remporter un tournoi
majeur et ce sera vraiment dommage parce
que certains parmi les plus grands
joueurs ont leurs noms associés à une
victoire en coupe du monde et messi et
ronaldo ne l'auront pas mais cela
n'enlèvera rien à leur talent et à leur
stature de joueurs cependant ce serait
vraiment le couronnement de leur
carrière s'il pouvait faire gagner leur
pays en coupe du monde
[Musique]
tout comme leur style de jeu leur
comportement et leur mode de vie leur
choix et projets futurs différeront pour
messi et ronaldo
l'avenir des super stars du football est
toujours compliqué je ne pense pas
qu'ils deviendront entraîneur aucun des
deux à moins que je me trompe parce que
pour être entraîneur ou directeur
sportif il faut écouter l'un expliqué à
l'autre parler à tout le monde en fait
ce sont des jobs très ingrat pour les
footballeurs et ceux qui ont atteint le
top comme en ce moment messi et ronaldo
qui représentent l'élite qui sont
presque les meilleurs joueurs de
l'histoire eux ça ne leur apporterait
rien ça leur coûterait plus qu'autre
chose
rester dans le monde du football en tant
qu'entraîneur ou gestionnaires
ne suis pas sûr qu'ils le feraient
beaucoup de joueurs soit 6 q là dedans
ils ont encore quelque chose à prouver
quand ils terminent leur carrière de
joueur vous savez ils ont une raison de
continuer ni d'en faire plus
quelle raison aurait ces deux ya là de
faire quoi que ce soit de plus ils n'ont
rien à prouver il n'est pas étonnant que
les gens croient que messi continuera à
vivre la même vie qu'aujourd'hui
tranquille et dans l'intimité non je
pense que lionel messi sera très
probablement un de ces joueurs qui va
tranquillement s'éloigner il se
détachera simplement et doucement de
l'univers du football je crois que
autant ronaldo que messi ne se sont pas
encore demandé ce qu'ils allaient faire
dans le futur
aujourd'hui rien ne sont que des
footballeurs
l'enfance qui l'ont hué le temps
qu'elles ont investi dans le football ne
leur ont pas laissé le temps de
d'étudier et de se former à un autre
métier
sincèrement je crois qu'ils voudront
vivre de leur entreprise ils en ont
beaucoup
cristiano à ses hôtels
leo messi est bien c'est vraiment un
mystère on sait qu'il a beaucoup investi
dans des marques de vêtements
mais on ne sait pas réellement ce qu'ils
font
est il possible que messi puisse quitter
l'espagne pour son cher pays natal
mais j'aimerais qu'il reste vivre ici
qu'il vit nouvelle époque de sa vie
marcel je pense qu'il se sent heureux
dans son monde parallèle au fond
je sais qu'il s'est lancé dans quelques
petits projets d'entreprises arrivent et
je crois aussi qu'il veut retourner à
rosario sa ville natale et je le compte
il veut jouer en première division
d'argentine avec les noël je crois bien
qu'il le fera un jour ou l'autre à 35 36
ans il pourrait bien jouer jusqu'à 40
ils le voulaient ils adorent le football
après ça la maison rester à la maison
avec ses enfants et sa femme je ne vois
pour suivre aucune autre carrière
je ne vois pas devenir entraîneur il
rentrera rosario je crois s'il pense que
l'argentine est un pays qui a de
l'avenir ou alors il s'occupera juste
des enfants dans l'académie des
nouvelles je ne vois vraiment rien
d'autre
peut-être un peu de politique aussi pour
messi parce que l'argentine et son pays
mais il a quitté très jeune et certaines
personnes se demandent combien il y est
encore attaché si les retrouve vraiment
ses racines mais on a bien l'impression
qu'il aimerait y retourner pour apporter
du bien à son pays
quant à ronaldo il restera sous le feu
des projecteurs
dans quarante ans qu'on verra encore
cristiano ronaldo ouvrons des hôtels se
montrant aux premières des galas de la
fifa car je pense que ce style de vie
d'après football 4 aura parfaitement
avec ronaldo je pense que nous
retrouveront probablement quelqu'un
trenado plus d'une fois dans les médias
quand j'aurai fini ma carrière je veux
m'engager dans l'univers de la mode j'ai
ça dans le sang il ya eu des rumeurs
comme quoi ronaldo pourrait un jour
apparaître au cinéma
c'est un homme qui est une machine à
courir qui qui d'une certaine façon on
ne sait pas que cette machine s'arrêtera
jamais elle s'arrêtera
nous verrons alors ce qui se passera
il s'écroulera parce qu'il veut être sur
le devant de la scène en permanence mais
à ce moment là les lumières s'éteindront
mais il a surmonté des obstacles bien
plus redoutable il se relèvera à la fin
et se dira en mai j'ai quatre hôtels et
puis je m'occupe de plein d'autres
choses et ça fera survivre et si en même
temps lui propose deux ou trois
scénarios à hollywood
enfin vivre leur vie je pense que c'est
ce qu'ils feront parce qu'on a pas de
vie quand on est aussi célèbre et aussi
talentueuse que
je crois qu'ils vont très bien vivre
parce qu'ils ont été messier ronaldo
pendant de nombreuses années et qui le
seront pour des générations
peu importe où ils finiront ils ont tous
les deux commencé au bas de l'échelle en
dur et de lourdes épreuves pour réussir
et avec beaucoup de travail et un peu de
chance tous deux ronaldo et messi sont
devenus des légendes
[Musique]
ils survivront dans l'histoire du
football comme deux des plus grands
athlètes du ballon rond
il aura 60 ans et nous irons toujours le
voir j'irai le voir je lui dirai les oh
mon dieu c'était le bon temps je regarde
toujours les vidéos parce que je pense
que nous n'allons jamais jamais revoir
un jeu pareil
ce qui serait magnifique plus tard tout
sera fini qu'ils auront 40 ou 50 ans ce
serait de les installer sur une plage
dans les caraïbes de les laisser parler
et voir ce qu'il en sort parce qu'il
finirait probablement part raconté
beaucoup de choses à propos de chacun
d'eux et je pense que ce serait un
moment très spécial parce que comme je
les dis ce sont deux joueurs
exceptionnels
messi est un joueur incroyable
peut-être qu'au fond il m'a poussé à
être encore plus fort
pour moi je suis le meilleur et je
travaille comme les meilleurs
donc ce sera ma façon de voir ma vie
jusqu'à la fin
qui est le plus grand
eh bien
c'est à vous de décider
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]